this Netflix series is about a girl
named Nano in which each chapter we will
see her in a new school solving some
Society issues even if it takes a
killing sacrifice each chapter is
independent and based on true stories of
young ties so today on Cinema recap I'll
show you girl from nowhere this story is
about a school that claims to be very
pure where there is a teacher who likes
to have relations with the girls at
school so Nano gets involved in all this
to be able to take revenge for all the
girls he has threatened Nano records an
intimate moment between the teacher's
daughter and her boyfriend then
threatens a teacher to publish this
video if he does not give him the
password to his computer he ends up
giving in and after accessing the
computer Nano copies all the
compromising videos of the teacher and
publishes them so the teacher's family
finds out and such news causes his
daughter to be ran over
the next day the police arrested the
teacher while the whole school falls
into disgrace because of what the
teacher did this story is about two
friends who are envious of Nano since
she has all the attention of the boys
so these two friends will try to attack
her the two friends drug Nano and let
three boys abuse her however something
goes wrong and they end up murdering
Nano so they decide to bury the body and
then apologize to her
the next day they are surprised because
Nano is alive and attends school so the
five boys kill her one more time but she
revives over and over again
so they begin to go crazy while Nano
shows them a lesson a simple apology
does not always fix things and even less
if you apologize but commit the same
mistake again this Story begins with a
girl who is pressured a lot to be a
great artist so Nano tells her to get
inspiration from other artists to create
her own paintings but the girl begins to
copy other artworks and she earns Awards
and fame from that
however as she was just copying other
people's work Nano gets angry and
pressures the girl to paint something
new in front of other people
and although the girl tries to avoid so
by hammering her own hand she ends up on
stage where another girl shows up with
evidence that the girl copies other
paintings in that moment the girl paints
a picture that is not so good but at
least it's original so everyone applauds
her
and everyone learns that people
shouldn't take over other people's work
but you should let that work inspire you
this new story is about a boy who is
poor but pretends to be rich since he
attends a school for Rich students one
day his friends want to go to his house
so the boy asked Nana to get him a big
house in exchange for money Nano then
get to my house but the boy's surprise
on the day of the party as he realizes
that the Servants of the house are his
parents
then his friends began to play Russian
Roulette for money and they also began
to mistreat his parents at the point of
beating them
however they pay the parents to not say
anything about what happened
so when the boy arrives at his real
house and sees his parents hurt he feels
very bad so he learns that money can buy
many things but it can also destroy
others this story is about a boy who in
order to look cool and gain Fame decides
to become Nano's boyfriend because all
the students ship them together however
this boy already had a girlfriend and
she asked him to end a fake relationship
with Nano but when the boy tries to
break up with Nano she tells him that he
can never leave her because that would
ruin his popularity Zoe decides to send
his girlfriend to kill Nano and then he
pretends to mourn her death however he
finds out the Nano survived what is in a
coma and now as a good boyfriend he must
take care of her for the rest of his
life
because everyone has their eyes on him
so here we learn
that some people will do anything to
have some Fame those people can be very
toxic when they see a couple with social
media
this is a story about a girl who felt
hatred and jealousy for Nano since all
the boys in the football team loved her
including her own lover
then this girl begins to write ugly
things about Nano in the bathroom and
realizes that whatever she writes
becomes reality so the girl begins to
attack Nano by writing that her face
smells bad and she has pimples she also
attacks another student using this magic
but by doing so she almost kills the
janitor but decides to delete the phrase
before anything could happen this girl
tells one of her friends about this
magic and the friend tells everyone
about it and the chaos begins because of
all the hatred they have
so the girl decides to stop Everyone by
erasing everything they wrote
because she and her lover had also been
affected
however all the students chase her and
try to stop her so in desperate moment
she rides on the wall I wish everyone
disappeared
making all people disappear including
herself shortly after the Story begins
with a boy who likes to steal a lot
because he wants the attention of his
father who is never with him and is a
millionaire
the Nano approaches this boy and they
become friends they both steal together
for a long time then one day Nana
proposes that the boy steals some money
from the director of the school they
plan it out but the boy is discovered
and also learns that Nano played him
pretty badly since she gave him away
the boys expelled the next day and that
is when he sees his father
who knowing that his son wanted to go on
his own now decides to go see him and
the boy hugs him happily it is then that
he realizes that Nano's plan was to make
his father come back
he goes and thanks Nano and says goodbye
and the morrow is people do not
appreciate what they have until they
lose it in this story students are
locked in a classroom because of a
serial killer who's on the loose and
disguised as a student they begin to
argue amongst themselves because the
teacher only wants to take care of his
daughter
a boy steals a bottle of water from
another student who had denied water to
the teacher's daughter and then they
decide to ask for help so one by one
they go out everyone gets lost because
the school's so dark and suddenly they
see that someone in the group has been
killed
they think it was a murderer but at that
moment they see on the news that the
murder is already dead and he did not
kill any of the students
so one of them committed the murder
because of the hatred that was built
when they were locked up and they
learned that distrust lack of empathy
and concern for themselves can corrupt
Society this is a story about a teacher
whose classes are too serious unlike
other teachers who talk like friends to
their students
so most of the students do not want her
except Nano
we also realized that her husband left
her and he took their son with him then
we see that the teacher is very angry
about how the educational system is and
how students are nowadays and decides to
change this however she is very cruel to
the students and begins to go a little
crazy to the point of stabbing a student
with a pen because of this she gets
fired from the school but then decides
to tag along on a school event and kill
all the students and teachers in Revenge
to how the world has treated her
and then takes her own life we learn
here that sometimes we blame other
people for the evils we have this is a
story of a girl who attends a school
where beauty is the most important thing
and the 10 most beautiful girls are
treated like queens and the protagonist
is rated at position 10. one day she
gets pimples and loses his position so
she begins to do everything possible to
climb back however when she can't get
more beautiful she begins to injure the
other girls staining their faces cutting
their hair and even fights with one of
them in the end she's the only one left
who is beautiful however on the day the
school announces the most beautiful girl
she doesn't win this makes her very
angry because a girl who won was the one
she said was very ugly
later she realizes that everyone can be
beautiful this is a story where several
people meet in the classroom to
celebrate their 10-year reunion since
they graduated school
they dig up a time capsule of memories
and realize that one of their
ex-classmates is missing they say that
the missing girl was crazy because
another girl discovered her pretending
to speak on the phone when she doesn't
have any registered calls
then while they keep talking about her
this girl shows up and we see that they
were talking about Nano
and then she begins to reveal secrets of
them all Nano reveals that she did not
fake any calls because she was talking
to the boyfriend of the girl who accused
her of being crazy and that for this
reason the girl had beaten and abused
her along with other companions Nano
tells the girl that her boyfriend had
been cheating on her with her best
friend and a confrontation is set up
where the girl is injured and they
realize she is pregnant Nano tells
everybody that she has poisoned them and
that there is only one cure shot so they
all start fighting each other to death
then Nano tells him that it was all a
joke and they try to kill her but they
pass out Nano leaves the next day
everyone wakes up and everything seems
to have been a nightmare however they
learned that sometimes having a friend
in common can unite people but other
times it can make you realize that
you're not as close friends as you
thought this is the story about a boy
who is popular at school for getting
girls pregnant but then he needs Nano
the new girl and decides to do the same
as the others how Ronaldo knows what he
wants and decides to make him pay Nano
sleeps with him but he is the one who
ends up getting pregnant so he leaves
school because they made fun of him he
also gets kicked out of his house so he
tries to do everything to stop his
pregnancy but he can't do it
then he asked Nano to take
responsibility for the baby but she
ignores him the boy gives birth and
although at first he wanted to kill his
son he ends up taking care of him
learning what the girls felt like when
he got them pregnant in the end of the
episode we see that someone is looking
for Nano this is a story about a school
that had separated the boys from the
girls
School principal decides to put them
together again so the teachers begin to
set some rules since one of the girls
had a bad experience with the boys in
the past thanks to Nano they look for
new ways to communicate then the
principal decides to fire a teacher and
when he says goodbye to her another
teacher declares her love to him and he
decides to kiss her accepting love in
his life so the principal learns that
love is not a bad thing although some
people use it with bad intentions at the
end we see that Nano was chatting with a
girl in a red bun who was the one that
was looking for her in the previous
chapter this chapter begins with a girl
who is the daughter of a rich man
she's very rebellious and a liar
then one night she's drunk driving and
ends up running over four people killing
them and one of them being Nano however
thanks to her father and to the fact
that she lied by saying that the brakes
in her car did not work she avoids
prison by only paying a bail
however every day she feels tormented by
the deaths and when she leaves the
courthouse she gets in a car accident
with her parents
taken to the hospital and there she
realizes that in the news they say that
it was discovered that she was drunk
after all so now she will have to go to
jail
but at that moment the mysterious girl
with the red bun appears and helps her
take her own life so she doesn't learn
the lesson of facing the consequences of
her actions and then we see that the
girl on the red bun named Yuri meets
with Nano in this chapter we get to know
Yuri who was a poor girl who obeyed two
other rich girls at school in exchange
for money
then they met Nano and kidnapped her to
record videos torturing her however
something went wrong and the rich girls
end up killing Nano on camera so Yuri
took the video and threatened the rich
girls to publish it and also brought two
guys to abuse these two girls while she
went to see Nano Yuri makes fun of Nano
and at that moment the boy she had hired
drowned her and leave
then Nano wakes up and mocks Yuri and
also left for there this chapter begins
with a boy who makes many of the new
students suffer because according to him
and his friends it is a school tradition
we also see that Nano and Yuri are there
something goes wrong and the boy ends up
killing Nano so he is transferred to
another school where he will have to go
through initiation ritual himself also
he runs into Nano again but in that
school she is one of the highest grade
students Nano makes him go through many
unpleasant things such as dressing up as
a woman playing as a dog or sleeping in
a cage until Yuri messes with Nano's
plans and causes them to end up killing
the boy which Nana does not like this is
a story about a school where they have
very strict rules and Nano arrives to
break them all so they punish her many
times until Yuri arrives and immediately
changes all of Nano's plans Yuri gives
Nano some important documents and as she
is going to share them with the students
Yuri gets in the way and throws her from
High height and blames one of the
t-shirts for it then exposes the
information and all the students go
crazy against the teachers
however the principle stops all the
students by threatening them with the
gun but at that moment Nano arrives and
challenges him to kill her in front of
all the cameras so he refuses and the
students knock him down getting their
freedom back juanano punishes Yuri for
messing with her plans this chapter is
about a girl whose parents made herself
products online by being an influencer
one day she gets tired and with Nano's
help she fakes her own death to be able
to escape from that world however Yuri
appears and tells the world the truth so
the influencer kills Nano and says that
she had kidnapped her
but when she comes back home she
realizes that not only stole her life
and now everyone says that Nano is a
real influencer in that moment the girl
remembers that she was the one who asked
her parents to make her an influencer
and they did so because they loved her
the fans accused a girl of being a
scammer and she tries to run away before
the police take her but before asking
Nano she really deserves all that
we see that Nano's wounds are not
healing as quickly as before and Yuri
tells her that maybe she's becoming
mortal the final chapter is about a
mother who took care of her daughter who
had a disease however Nano investigates
and realizes that the mother was the one
who kept her daughter Sick by poisoning
her the mother explains to Nano that she
keeps her daughter weak because she is a
psychopath and kills people
she is a good mother just trying to
protect her the daughter hears his
conversation and with Yuri's help
manages to get up and fight her mother
Nano and Yuri wonder who is the real
guilty one in this mess and at that
moment the daughter tries to kill the
mother but Nano gets in the way then the
mother decides that the guilty one is
nano for revealing the secret and
decides to kill her but the daughter
kills her first at the end Yuri
tanzanana tells her that now she will
give power to people and let them be
responsible for their actions and also
gives her blood to the psychopath girl
if you like this video please leave a
like And subscribe to continue receiving
the Recaps of the best and bizarre
horror series my name is TC and I'll see
you in the next video goodbye